from car bombs
to gun attacks
to the attempted murder of another
police officer there's nothing new about
the new Ira the umbrella name for
Renegade Irish Republican factions still
fighting the same old war against
British rule in Ireland Allison Morris
the Belfast telegraph's crime
correspondent says they have been
heavily infiltrated by MI5 that is why
we've seen the threat level in Northern
Ireland last year lured because mfa's
assessment was that they had been almost
mortally wounded in terms of their
ability to carry out attacks but we
always say you know and those groups
always say they only have to get lucky
once whereas the security forces have to
get lucky every single time to thwart
those attacks and I don't think that
anyone had anticipated an attack such as
what happened on DCI Caldwell
dissident Republicans have murdered
policemen soldiers and prison officers
the journalist Lira McKee was killed
when they opened fire on police during a
riot
police North and South say the terror
group has aligned with the firm an
unlikely Alliance of terrorists and
criminals it's a complex and nuanced
security situation adding to the
challenge of post-brex attentions and
threatening the fragile peace
Tony Blair the Prime Minister who
co-brokered the Good Friday agreement is
calling for leadership how capable are
the political leaders of today of
grasping
the nuances of Northern Ireland and
helping to resolve it if they think that
piece has been a good thing
remember this one
principle which is actually a principle
about leadership it only came about
because of leadership
it only came about because there were
leaders prepared to be unpopular even
with their own Grassroots constituency
or part of it and it only came about
because there were Leaders with the
creativity and the imagination to say
whatever the obstacles we're going to
find their way through and they found it
it's a chilling reminder of why policing
in Northern Ireland is different to
anywhere else in the United Kingdom the
fears of the past are never far from the
hopes of the future David Blevins Sky
News in Belfast